so let's get into some of the
controversial stuff over here and I've
got some summary notes for my researcher
which I'll do before we start taking the
questions um okay so let's do the Taylor
Swift scop one
first uh got to get some audio on this
one is Taylor Swift aop share audio tab
all right so let's just play this over
here get some volume for you it's just
over a minute long but just have a
listen conspiracy theories around Taylor
Swift rigging the Super Bowl are
swirling let me explain it seems to have
started earlier in January with Fox News
talking head Jesse Waters floating the
idea that the pop star is a government
scop on his show well around 4 years ago
the Pentagon psychological operations
unit floated turning Taylor Swift into
an asset during a NATO meeting he then
played a clip from this 2019
International Conference on Cyber
conflict to back up his claim so I
include Taylor Swift in here because
she's um you know she's a fairly
influential online person I don't know
if you've heard of her however how much
you want to bet that this G was one of
her big fans the woman in the clip shown
indeed does not work for the Pentagon as
Fox's Waters said she was a researcher
at John Hopkins at the time and was
giving a presentation about how
influential people can combat
misinformation online days after he made
the allegation a pentagon spokesperson
denied the claim using Taylor Swift
lyrics to respond saying quote as for
this conspiracy we're going to shake it
off Swift endorsed Biden and I mean they
wouldn't admit to it if they were doing
it now would they right 2020 and urged
her followers to register to vote this
is Al being used by many online to
inform their conspiracy theories about
Taylor Swift they see her relationship
with Kansas City chief star Travis Kelce
and the media focus on their
relationship as reason to believe she's
being used as a s up to rig the Super
Bowl and influence Americans to vote for
Joe Biden this November then this past
Monday former presidential candidate Vic
ramaswami wrote on x quote I now I'm
just going to pause this for a sec CU I
want to read what Jack uh poo wrote in
advance to Vivic responding to it uh it
might be harder to see on the screen so
he says thinking about when Taylor Swift
called out the Soros family in 2019 for
buying the rights to her music we'll get
to that in a little bit and how then she
came out super liberal in 2020 keep in
mind she was completely quiet up until
about 2019 2020 when it came to
political opinions uh which way she
leaned until Soros bought her entire
catalog of Music which we'll get to
another clip in a little bit but Vivic
over here responds and I'll just let uh
the narrator uh read it and play it
quote I wonder who's going to win the
Super bowl next month and I wonder if
there's a major presidential endorsement
coming from an artificially culturally
propped up couple this
fall okay so that's that's one of them
and that wasn't as uh damning as the one
that I'm about to play you right now so
let me close this
window and so this is one uh that was
snip together on Instagram yeah okay so
let's play this one this guy by the way
I don't know who he is it says the Benny
show I've never heard of him Benny uh
Johnson um he sounds a lot like Tucker
Carlson or he sounds like he's trying to
mimic the Tucker Carlson way of of uh
speaking but just listen to this one
this one's a little more
daming um that's tswift Instagram and
share and play that political and George
Soros bought all of the rights to her
music this is real my entire catalog was
sold to scooter bronze itha Holdings in
a deal that I'm told was funded by the
Soros family 23 capital and the Carlile
group enter operation Taylor Travis
Kelce was not a big-time celebrity so
suddenly this dude who like I've never
heard of and you've probably never heard
of it becomes the face of budlight a
little strange Choice isn't it this
premere A
became the face of fiser and the
covid-19 injection Travis did you know
you can get this season's co9 shot 18%
of Voters say they're more likely or
significantly more likely to vote for a
candidate endorsed by Taylor Swift this
published today from The New York Times
pred programming oh yeah what's
happening with Taylor Swift is not
organic or natural it's an OP we all
feel it and we all know
it all
right so there's that now
why the hell would George Soros buy her
entire catalog of music and why would
she go and start to lean left after that
happened overtly um there's a tweet here
that she put out I've got queued up on
my screen
and this is from 2020 May 29 2020 she
says after stoking the fires of white
supremacy and racism your entire
presidency you guys decide whether or
not Trump was that guy or not you have
the nerve to feain moral superiority
before threatening violence when the
Looting starts the shooting starts we
will vote you out in November and then
she tagged at real Donald Trump again
very quiet about her opinions prior to
that uh to that 2019 date when uh the
Soros family bought her entire catalog
so here's what popped up from my
researcher I'm just going to go down
these over here on my other screen um
it's kind of all over the place but
quick quick bio
so I mean okay so let's start with
Travis right uh born October 5th 1989
they're about the same age by the way
she's uh also an 89 baby but December
13th apparently he's an excellent tight
end biggest
controversy uh that could be found on
Travis really was uh dorky tweets about
him feeding a squirrel bread yes believe
it or not they made a big stink about
that or loving IHOP uh apparently these
were tweets that he tried to delete or
remove from the history and he also
talked about breeder which I mentioned
earlier looking for mother stock so I
mean we'll get to whether or not Taylor
Swift's good mother stock in a moment
when we get to the red flags um but the
feminists hated the whole breeder
conversation uh he took the knee in 2017
during national anthems uh that was just
the one time that I was able to find it
it apparently happened more than that
but that's just you know the one image
that was uh captured you guys know what
was going on you know in those days um
it was all protest against uh Donald
Trump and his
presidency um and they you know they
cooked up all kinds of ideas about him
being all kinds of phobics and isms and
um you know there were athletes that
were taking you've got this dude Travis
Kelce who's clearly white he's he not
white woke um he he's he's he's woke to
the sense that he took on sponsorship
and marketing money from budlight and
fizer uh for the VAC sponsor deals which
you saw the commercials on earlier uh if
you aren't familiar and have been
sleeping under a rock budlight was was a
company that in a recent past had hired
um trans influencer Dylan
Mulaney um who's walking around calling
himself a girl uh but he still calls
himself Dylan um anyway budlight took
him on and that was a colossal train
wreck they lost a whole [__] ton of
market share um their target
demographics stopped buying the beer and
I guess they try to correct that by
paying uh Travis Kelce a whole ton of
money um to be their spokesperson and
also you know fizer did the same thing
to encourage people to go get the
experimental jab his net worth is $30
million so let's go to Tailor's
which is uh a lot more colorful uh let's
do her n worth first so she's worth $1.1
billion uh that is a
significant s a massive amount of money
more than what kelse is worth uh to put
that in perspective Travis Kelce is
worth only
2.7% of uh Taylor Swift's netw worth
it's a very very small amount um when it
comes to the notion of women and men and
pair bonding over a long term it's been
said many many times that women are have
a strong preference to made AC cross and
up on the socioeconomic scale in this
case uh Travis would be uh down in the
socio economic scale uh which isn't a
strong predictor of a good long-term
relationship or marriage but that being
said the chick's worth 1.1 billion
dollar uh there's not a lot of available
guys in that space um that she's going
to be interested in dating because of
course she's got to manage the Optics of
you know who she's dating because she's
a Prof performer she's a musician uh her
all of the guys from her past are quote
unquote famous um and noteworthy and
generally around her age in some cases a
little bit younger she's dated younger
as well um but it's unlikely that a
check worth 1.1 billion dollars that's
also 34 uh is going to take on a 50 you
know 50-year-old guy right that's not in
her character or based on her past
character and again you know the best
predictor of somebody's future is going
to be their past Behavior avior so
that's what I'm looking at
here uh born December 13389 written
songs professionally at age 14 200
million records sold highest grossing
female touring act ever uh most stream
woman on Spotify and apple music Forbes
world's 100 most powerful women uh Swift
is a philanthropist and an advocate for
artist rights and women's empowerment
including uh abortion rights um she's on
terrible terms with most of her exes
with the exception of t tlor lner who
she dated back in 2009 who apparently
she's still friends with didn't see
anything about her and him connecting
very often publicly maybe it happens
maybe it doesn't um albums I'm not going
to read them boring as [__] um there's a
whole bunch of them there's 14 here uh
she's been putting out albums since 2006
started out as a country music uh
performer uh NFL draft Travis let's see
Catching touchdown both wins whatever
you know you can get that off of
Wikipedia um President Biden's
re-election team apparently was seeking
Swift's endorsement in 20120 and the way
that she's setting up for this election
cycle it looks like that the team's
already working on that right now um the
Super Bowl is more important than
anything political as it stands so um
any opinions she has right now are going
to be sidelined with the importance of
the Super Bowl is probably it's it's got
to be the most watch
event on TV on a yearly basis in the
United States um so you can expect
Snippets of her to show up I don't know
if she's performing I don't know if
they've announced who's performing um
but there's going to be lots of scenes
of her popping up expect so this is a
prediction I'm just predicting this I'm
not saying it's happened but I think if
you watch the Super Bowl I'm not
interested you'll probably see lots of
highlights you know the camera swinging
oh there's Taylor in the stands there's
Taylor you know cheering on Travis oh
here's Taylor again you know sort of
thing um expect
that uh we talked about her September uh
tweet or sorry her Instagram post uh
encouraging at that time 272 million
followers to register to vote uh that
post led to more than 35,000 new
registrations on the nonpartisan
nonprofit vote.org site uh 6 and 10 us
adults called themselves at least a
casual fan of the singer with 8% saying
they're raving
fans uh pop culture people identify with
this stuff they pay attention to it and
it's what moves politics now it's
attention and identity um this is a
professor at Monclair state universities
whose research includes the intersection
of politics and pop culture I don't
think there's any question as to whether
or not an influential person that
makes overt statements to a captive
audience can sway opinion people are
sheep we saw what happened during the
scam several years ago they say JUMP
vast majority of people said H how high
they said stand on dots no problem wear
two masks how about three take two jobs
how about four you know sort of thing um
people people like a ruler they like to
be led um so in the absence of leading
themselves which most people don't
they're going to turn to pop culture and
in this case she's a very very very
influential person I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out